[Music]
we put together a good plan and then the
next day the president saying free
michigan free virginia i didn't quite
understand this misplaced perception
about people's individual right to make
a decision that supersedes the societal
safety
worse yet it superseded what i told
everyone to do
oh yeah i marched myself right into that
oval office i said listen here mr bond
mr trump i said who do you think you are
just because you're the president
and people voted for you
and you swore an oath to defend the
constitution and people's rights that
you have the right to tell me what to do
i'm dr fauci
and so anyway i thought that was where
we went very very awry and fortunately
we don't need to worry about that
anymore
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of lord or lady in
scotland just like me your humble host
lord michael knowles all you need is a
one square foot plot of land and a
certificate established titles is a
project based on an historic scottish
custom where landowners are referred to
as lards
or lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you will receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land
you can even get a couple pack for you
and your spouse or loved one of
unspecified distinction you will be able
to have land right next to one another
at one square foot and you will both get
to be called lord and lady you can get
this on your credit card on your plane
tickets you can even put it on your
dating profiles
established titles currently having a
massive holiday sale on top of that sale
you can get an additional 10 off any
purchase you make with discount code
knowles so click the link below or go to
establishtitles.com knowles use promo
code noel to save an extra 10
today
[Music]
[Music]
you